Turks living abroad have until august
3rd to cast their ballot Berlin alone is
home to 140,000 Turkish citizens of
voting age one polling station has been
set up in the Olympic Stadium ish video
optimized I am voting for the very first
time I've been in Berlin for 43 years
and never voted I don't know what
difference it'll make but I'm pleased to
be able to do my part all my entire
White Falcon there are numerous polling
stations across Berlin but potential
voters had to register and make
appointments in advance the Electoral
Commission says of the 2.8 million
eligible Turks abroad only ten percent
signed up before voting got underway the
media had to leave drawing criticism
from some that it amounted to curtailing
press freedom what the deepest I don't
understand why they made representatives
of Turkish and German media leave I
lodged a complaint at the consulate
depending on the response i might call
for the elections to be annulled the
Turkish ambassador chose instead to
focus on the fact that for the first
time expat Turks can now vote abroad
dust mentioned it is a good sign that
people want to vote and can do so it is
good to participate in the democratic
process the makati food eat i'll harbor
expand Turks who didn't sign up in time
to vote abroad can still cast their
ballots if they visit Turkey the
election there takes place on August
10th